Tell me.
Who hasn't ever dreamed of a cruise around the Greek islands stopping by my
clonus Santa rainy roads or the more than 1000 islands that Greece has spread
throughout the Aegean.
We are almost talking about a paradise about the Holy grail of the pre COVID
tourist who could resist such a journey. I can only think of one such person,
Recep, Tayyip, Erdogan.
I'm really sorry if I got that pronunciation completely wrong friends.
These hundreds of Greek islands in the GNC have become a nightmare for the
Turkish president's plans. And in Athens, they are perfectly aware of this.
And of course,
after seeing what happened to Jamal Khashoggi and taken to with Liam Neeson,
you know, instant bull is no joking matter, precisely because of this.
In this video,
we are going to look at how Greece is preparing for what may happen.
Are you ready? Well, let's get into it.
Not long ago.
Recent Turkey were in the news because of an earthquake,
but difference visual politics.
The clashes between Ankara and Athens have been beyond seismic since way back.
For example,
the last significant clash has been on the account of what is happening in the
Eastern Mediterranean, where under the sea in the subsoil,
natural gas has been found or raw material that Erdogan is not willing to give
up even a single cubic meter off.
But of course the question is whether or not it is really up to Turkey to
exploit the deposits that have been found.
And the truth is that with so many Greek islands in the way not to mention
Cyprus,
let's see that in principle maritime law does not seem to favor the Ottomans
European union itself has made a subtle defense of the maritime borders of its
members. Something which of course, Erdogan is not prepared to accept for today.
2D kit, you do six, seven millimeter currently
[inaudible] on kilometer currently. Other, you said in that
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] Ernie.
The Island Ertegun refers to is Castile or it's it's the Eastern most inhabited
Greek islands Idea.
It is situated more than 500 kilometers from the Greek mainland,
but it's barely two kilometers from the Turkish coast.
And even though Ertegun mentions this Island,
the truth is that he could be referring to practically any other because in the
GNC of the more than 100 islands that have been inhabited only to belong to
Turkey,
we are talking about islands that if we read the international maritime law seem
to give Greece of the rights to exploit the resources of the subsoil while
simultaneously excluding their Turkish neighbors,
given this backdrop and knowing what we do know about the Turkish president,
it doesn't seem likely that Erdogan will take this lying down.
Does it well in Athens, they have exactly the same impression.
So they are already getting their act together and preparing for even the worst
case scenario, direct confrontation.
Because even though it may seem to us like fiction or a highly improbable
outcome of events, Greece is willing to defend what it considers its own,
but okay, we know that the Turkish army is one of the largest in the world.
So what do we know about the Greek army? Well,
basically that things haven't changed much since qinglian.
You see.
Arrival of Donald Trump as president of the United States put the NATO demand
that its members reach a military expenditure of 2% of their national GDP back
on the table,
only 10 of the 30 countries in the Atlantic Alliance meet this objective.
And in this ranking,
Greece reaches a surprising second place just behind the United States.
The problem is that Greece is the only country that proportionally spends.
Most of its military spending on paying him.
There's an elk.
There may only be 300 of those fighters,
but at least they seem to be well-paid these days. Anyway,
what's happening in Greece is very interesting. On the one hand,
it spends its money on its personnel. And on the other hand,
any surplus that it could devote to military equipment is used to defend itself
from Turkey, which happens to be another NATO country. What nonsense.
So why is there so much resentment between Greeks and Turks is Greece prepared
to defend itself from Turkey and perhaps the most important question of all
could the Greek economy cope with the pressure of a possible conflict today?
Visual politic, we will answer these questions,
but first let's take a little look at some history.
The treaty of Lou song.
There are many things that separate Greece and Turkey, apart from the Aegean.
This is not simply a border between two countries. No,
it's a border that separates two continents, two religions, two civilizations,
East and West,
a frontier afflicted by centuries and centuries of confrontation or border
friends that has been a hotspot since the Trojan war from Alexander.
The great two by Santiam to the Ottoman Turks. In fact,
current problems between Athens and instant ball are due to issues that go back
at least a century in time until just after the first world war or war,
that was a complete disaster for the Ottoman empire.
Yeah.
[Inaudible] in the war. The Salton was ready to accept the treaty of Sephora,
a treaty with concessions,
difficult to digest such as that's part of Anatolia will be occupied by Greece.
For this reason,
Turkish nationalists led by miss stuffer KML Ataturk took up arms and expelled
both the Greeks and the Sultan,
the new Turkish Republic then negotiated a new agreement.
The treaty of Lausanne,
a treaty that meant Greece would give up the Eastern phrase to a Jean islands
off the Dardanelles straits and its interests in Asia minor in return Turkey
renounced his claim to Cyprus and other possible interests in the GNC,
for instance, the islands of the Dodecanese.
Well,
the fact is that the treaty Lausanne is now almost a hundred years after it was
signed the cause of the main tensions between Greece and Turkey today.
And you will see that there are three things that have happened in the
intervening years that have upset the agreed.
[Inaudible].
Again with the Dodecanese islands,
which were Italy's when the treaty of Lausanne was signed,
were handed over to Greece after Italy's defeat in world war II. Secondly,
there are islets that were not expressly mentioned in the treaty of Lausanne,
but that geographically speaking belong to the Dodecanese archipelago,
it is therefore understood that they are Greek, but nevertheless,
the Turks claimed them as their own.
And finally treaty sets the territorial waters for the Aegean islands at three
miles, 4.8 kilometers later, Greece extended them to six miles.
That is 9.6 kilometers with no apparent objection from Turkey,
but what no one could have known then was that by the end of the 20th century,
commonly accepted international law would extend to the territorial waters to 12
miles or 19.3.
[Inaudible].
Because by then the troops of both countries had already fought in a direct
confrontation. The battleground was the Island of Cyprus,
an independent country where the Greek Cypriot majority rules,
but where there was a notable Turkish community. The fact is that in 1974,
Turkey invaded the Northern third of the Island and established the Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus,
which as we have covered in other videos is not internationally recognized.
And if we returned to the Aegean,
the most serious clash between Greeks and Turks took place in 1996 on EMEA and
uninhabited Island near the Dota Kenny's archipelago and friends,
the trigger for this conflict is very complex.
At Christmas.
1995,
a Turkish ship ran aground in front of the islet of Emir and refused Greek help
claiming that it was Turkish territory. Weeks later,
a Greek politician came to the Island and planted a Greek flag on it in revenge.
Some Turkish journalists from Turkish newspaper hurry yet,
went to the Island and replaced the flag with a Turkish one. Finally,
Athens sent nine Greek soldiers.
They camped on the Island and replaced the Greek flag,
the Greek military presence per half of the Turkish Navy on the warpath and the
Greek soon followed suit. What was about to be declared,
but the United States intervened to restore.
Cool.
This point, you might be wondering what on earth,
Greece and Turkey are fighting.
About lately? Well,
the point is that.
Turkey is one of the 20 or so countries that have not signed to the law of the
sea convention. We are talking about the UN treaty signed in Montego Bay,
which has regulated the international law of the sea since 1994, basically.
And Carra does not accept the article in the treaty that States that islands,
as well as the mainland have a continental shelf.
This is very important for the exploitation of economic resources.
Since Anne Cora claims that the Greek islands off the Turkish coast do not have
their own shelf fast. According to this viewpoint,
the zone of Greek influence in the Aegean would begin in continental Greece.
Under the zone of Turkish influence on the sea would not be limited by the Greek
islands bottom line, but gas would belong to the Turks. And on the other hand,
although Turkey accepts the 12 mile limit of territorial waters for all
countries.
It makes an exception for Greece and take notes because the issue of these 12
miles has made headlines again in 2020 among other things,
because in August Greece decided to extend its territorial waters in the Ionian
sea widget shares with Italy to 12 miles. And it didn't stop there.
Athens did not hesitate to assure that it would soon do the same in the Aegean.
Not surprisingly. The Turkish reaction was immediate.
Turkey says Greece's decision to extend its territorial waters in a gene is a
cause of war. Hurry yet daily news.
So far, it has not come to that,
but the situation is more complicated than it seems. At first glance,
You see the central right new democracy party regained power in Greece in mid
2019. But to a large extent,
it did stop at the cost of feeding a nationalist agenda in order to compete with
the extreme right views of the golden Dawn party,
the strategy has been successful,
but Kiriakos Mitsotakis the prime minister is now being held hostage by a
nationalist faction with a new democracy,
with enough MPS to overthrow his government.
On the other hand.
We all know the Turkish president Erdogan has been emphatic.
He assures that he will not allow the Aegean to become a Greek Lake.
And Kyra believes that if Greece were to extend its jurisdictional waters to 12
miles, Turkey would be limited in its freedom of navigation. In this map,
you can see how the political map of the Aegean would change. The question is,
how on earth can all this be solved?
Well.
Is complicated because Adam sees no need to negotiate anything.
The current situation suits them and they feel that sitting down to talk to
Turkey would mean making concessions with nothing to gain.
So the challenge now for the Mitsotakis government is not to get carried away by
nationalists in responding to Turkish provocations, wait a minute.
Provocations what provocations? Well, for example,
it is common for Turkish planes to invade Greek airspace.
And not only that recently Turkey sent to the ORIC res an exploration vessel to
do oil and gas prospecting in the vicinity of Casta rates.
So we are talking about an area that Greece considers as its exclusive economic
zone. In fact, a few months ago, the collision of a Greek for gate,
with a Turkish for gate escorting the ORIC race,
reignited the tensions in the air and take notes because it cannot be ruled out
that Turkey, which has taken the initiative unilaterally in scenarios,
such as Iraq and Syria could organize an amphibious military operation on
some Island in the Aegean and in the face of such a scenario. The question is,
how exactly is the Greek army placed? Could it deter the Turks?
How could it react to a possible attack?
Listen up.
There's is spa. Ah, if you were in charge.
Which of Greece, your first question would probably be,
how could Turkey hit us after Raul Erdogan has adopted a doctrine known as the
blue fatherland doctrine,
by which Turkey claims control of the waters of the Eastern Jian and the
Northern Mediterranean ignoring the rights generated by all Greek islands.
As you can imagine, this map has no international validity.
It is only valid if you are in Turkey or perhaps in a callback shop,
but friends, even with a good Turkish wrap,
the TURPs have not managed to convince anyone else. Of course,
that doesn't mean that anchor doesn't have a legal ACE up its sleeve.
Let me explain all those Greek islands in the East energy and were demilitarized
by the Montreux convention and international agreement signed in 1936.
However,
Greece claims it now has reason to mistrust Turkey since it invaded Cyprus,
more than 40 years ago, come on,
no amount of ouzo would persuade them to leave any of their islands defenseless.
So in the absence of tourists this year,
many Greek soldiers were seen or one of these Ajai in islands.
And of course the Turkish protest was not long in coming.
Turkey says Greece unlawfully put more troops on Casta, Louisa,
the national Herald. Given this scenario,
it seems evident where the Turkish threat could materialize any Island in the
Eastern Ajai and bathed in waters,
which Ann Kartra claims are a part of that blue fatherland.
And my friends at present,
everything points to a confrontation between Greece and Turkey being marked by a
clear Turkish superiority, both numerically and technologically. In fact,
they have their fourth army stationed in Izmir equipped with air and landing
capabilities.
What's more Turkey is about to have its first helicopter carrier developed by
the Turkish industry in a joint venture with stay with this,
the design of the Spanish company.
[inaudible] not only that the Turkish army is also equipped with more modern
weaponry and has its own arms industry at its disposal.
Something that Greeks lack.
Even. So.
The mid-scale confrontation would be more balanced than it seems.
Greece has been waiting for a Turkish move for decades and has the advantage
that the territory to be defended is very small.
So the Turkish numerical superiority would not be so important.
Of course the worst thing for Greece could be for Erdogan to bet on a fait
accompli scenario, a Putin style strategy,
if the annexation of the Crimea or test anything,
it is that the West response to the conquest of a territory is no longer as
energetic as one might expect.
I lightening operation by Turkey to take over an Island like catch that'll
reach.
So located a couple of kilometers off the Turkish coast and with a population of
barely 500 people would give Erdogan a bargaining chip with winch to force a
negotiation on his maritime rights in the Aegean and the Mediterranean
To avoid this situation. Greece is organizing a spot in defense of its islands.
That is in fact what explains the trip movements denounced by Turkey.
They have also set their sights on modernizing their army.
The Greek government is taking advantage of all the opportunities that it has at
its disposal.
The most obvious one can be seen with what has been happening with the most
modern fighters in the world. The F 35.
Let me.
Explain Turkey has been a close of the United States since the cold war.
So neither NATO nor the white house liked it.
One bit that Erdogan decided is to buy the S 400 triumph air defense system
from Russia.
Obviously it doesn't seem like a good idea to hand over one of your best fighter
planes,
to someone who works with the technicians who designed the missiles that are
supposed to take them down. So I'm in Athens and in Washington,
they quickly saw the business opportunity.
Greece will get six U S F 35 fighter jets slated for Turkey.
The national Herald.
Not only that Greece has also deployed its best diplomatic artistry to form a
block against Turkey.
That includes countries like Egypt with which it has concluded a maritime
demarcation agreement and the United Arab Emirates,
which is wary of Turkey's ties with its rival Qatar.
They also carry out military maneuvers with countries,
such as Cyprus and Israel,
which also class with Turkey over gas from the Mediterranean.
And they have taken very seriously. The idea of dazzling France and Italy,
two very influential countries that could eventually drag the European union
into confronting Ertegun Macron, for example,
has already shown stronger position to the Turkish president,
either out of conviction or the cause of what French politicians like best
business.
Greece is purchase of French made fighter jets worth 2 billion Euro,
Greek city times.
Right? A bill of 2 billion euros for Greece.
1.7 billion euros for 18 Rafale planes and another 300 million
euros in weaponry. That's more than $2.4 billion.
And this is not the end of the matter.
Almost 4 million people of Turkish origin live in Germany.
And is it for this reason? Berlin is very soft on Ertegun. Well,
it seems that the next Greek order will be for four for Gates from Berlin.
Now wait a minute. There is something that's grabbing your attention.
Have things changed so much in Greece that they can afford so much expenditure
on military.
From the drama to drama seems great.
Became a founding member of the Eurozone at the economic level.
It has created nothing but trouble.
They spent every last draft summer organizing the Olympic games.
And since then they have lived almost constantly on the brink of crisis for
years. The words tracker and rescue became more associated with this country,
then Greek yogurt itself. However,
since then the situation has improved considerably Greek ten-year government
bonds offer a yield of 0.68%. When in 2012,
they were close to 40%. Athens can now get into debt without too much trouble.
So what is the problem then? Well, the Corona virus has once again,
triggered Greece's appetite for debt and therefore the distrust of investors.
Greece sees public debt at 208.9% of GDP in
2020, Yahoo finance.
In November, Greece faced its second nationwide confinement.
The Greek economy will fall this year by more than 10%, as you can imagine,
it doesn't seem the best time for a war adventure in which Athens has nothing to
gain.
The military spending has grown by 10% since 2013, of course,
Turkish spending is three times higher.
Therefore even if they do want to modernize their armed forces,
I'm sure that nobody in Athens wants to see one of those fighter planes that
cost about 100 million euros get shot down in the Aegean.
So to avoid this scenario,
NATO has been the arena where Greece and Turkey have settled their differences
for the time being.
And what better way for an Alliance that emerged from the cold war then to
provide a solution in the form of bingo, a phone line.
Greece Turkey set up hotline to avoid clashes in Eastern Mediterranean NATO
says writers. Well.
As you can see at the moment,
it seems that the waters have calmed down in the Aegean.
It is not in the interest of either party to continue to stir up tension and a
confrontation would probably not outweigh any potential benefits to be gained.
But of course, when one of the players is Ertegun, anything can happen. Anyway,
that's an outline of what could unfold at visual politics.
We will be keeping an eye on what happens, but now it's your turn.
Do you think Greece is taking the right steps at a diplomatic and military level
to resist a Turkish offensive? Are you more of a fan of gyros or kebabs?
Leave your answer in the comments. So I really hope you've enjoyed this video.
Please hit like if you did, and don't forget to subscribe for brand new videos,
don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast.
They provided the vocals in this episode that were not mine. Also.
This channel is possible because of Patrion and that we're patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
And if you want to learn more about politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice, you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com slash podcast. See you there.